[Music]
thomas is in virginia alexandria to be
precise hi thomas how are you
i'm very good sir uh thank you for
taking my call really appreciate what
you do how are you doing sir better than
i deserve what's up
well i have a student loan question uh
since we are on the topic today and uh
just to let you know i'm uh just
recently married a month ago oh
congratulations
well thank you and my wife uh has always
been very disciplined with money and uh
i have been the opposite of that backing
up uh
debts from uh credit card to
student loan debt and uh medical debt
because i was uninsured for a while and
about a year over a year ago uh we had a
tension point while we were still dating
uh with how we spend money
and
so after reading your book uh really
took to the debt snowball and i'd been
paying off that before that but paid off
about uh 20 000 worth of medical and
student loan debt so right now i only
have the student loan debt left good for
you
and our question was is so when we came
together we she had a financial advisor
um
and she
has money and savings and retirement
with
right now the retirement's had over
half a million dollars and uh she
did the entire six-month emergency fund
so
with the remaining debt that i have
we could pay it off but the financial
advisor told us that
you know with everything that's
happening in dc and this talk of student
loan forgiveness up to 50 thousand
dollars that maybe would be smart to
wait a year to see if it actually
happens
and
just wondering what you think about that
well um
i think if you think that that's gonna
happen inside of a year
that um
you're dreaming
uh you know have you ever heard the
phrase it takes an act of congress and
the phrase means it takes forever
and it's not likely to happen
well this takes an act of congress
and it takes forever and it's not likely
to happen this is a political disaster
looking for a place to happen for
somebody
and uh it's not going to happen in a
year it would all they would already if
it was going to happen in a year there'd
already be bills on the floor
and they're just not they're not all
they're doing is popping their gums like
they always do they just run around
running their mouth just running their
mouth running their mouth and they don't
never do anything they just talk
and and just get on fox news and yell at
each other that's all they do
and so you're waiting around on those
people to fix your life not a chance
dude uh i think you probably need a new
financial advisor and i'd write a check
today and pay off the debt
okay no that's good advice and that's
what i was thinking too is is that you
know it and his viewpoint was as well
you know with the midterm elections you
know maybe with uh
um you know something will change within
the year so just to hold off wait wait
wait wait wait wait a minute the
republicans are not for student loan
forgiveness by and large
and with the ratings of the current
administration the midterm elections are
not going to bring in more democrats
unless something changes so it's going
to go the other way it's going to move
away from student loan forgiveness at
the midterm elections so once again
this guy's not a political analyst
either apparently so no i'm i'm not uh
you know you do what you want to do but
you called and asked me if i woke up in
your shoes i'd write a check today i'm
not sitting around waiting on washington
to fix my life
you have a long wait man
long wait
so i i would just be done with this you
borrowed the money
you could pay the money back there's a
neat idea and um move on with your life
man let's go let's go that's what i
would do thanks for calling in sir we
appreciate you
so um
there are some extreme situations
and i love grace
i like for folks to get a fresh start i
i the idea that some of you could have
your student loans wiped out
it you know it's
for those of you that are in pain with
this stuff i understand
but on the other hand
there's some principles involved in this
and
one of the principles is we shouldn't
keep making the loans before we have a
discussion about
forgiving them
that's intellectually dishonest
and again check out borrowed future
give it a watch tonight give the old
documentary look seed
you'll see what we're talking about it's
a mess out there y'all it's a mess and
congress made the mess